[Music]
you know it is hard to believe that it
has been 30 years since Kylie Minogue
became a household name with locomotion
flash forward to 2018 and Kylie's just
released her fourteenth studio album and
when I sat down with the icon at the
Roxy Hotel in Tribeca in New York she
told me this is her golden year yeah
she's turning 50 in May and last weekend
she even got a chance to perform for the
Queen on her birthday when you're on TV
the Queen is there anything they tell
you like you you're not supposed to do
is there yeah there's a host of rules
and and I managed to generally mess them
up but like I'll I'll I'll use the wrong
term or you know I've done the double
handshake Prince Charles like I don't
know why I did that I just I mean
literally but the Queen to meet a legend
she's 92 it's like there's all this
shining orb just comes floating and gets
closer to you and you don't really know
what you said I mean I've seen the
pictures from that and I'm just beaming
[Music]
Ali maybe dancing now but it was a very
different story last February when the
singer split from her fiance actor
Joshua sass the aftermath of the
break-up inspired Kiley to start working
on her fourteenth studio album golden
which sees the icon take on a pop
country sound had said there were songs
that you hadn't written yet that were
more personal and the dog didn't fit but
but they were cathartic why would you
not include them because they weren't
very good songs and also I didn't want
to break up album I mean once that
relationship was over things got better
it just was we we weren't suited to each
other so I don't want to keep rehashing
that so yeah it was about about finding
myself I wasn't heartbroken but I was a
bit broken yeah and I think everyone can
relate to that did it affect you
physically as well would you like
actually yeah yeah I when I was first in
the studio I am I like the mid-range of
my voice was just it it left the
building and I I was with writers and
producers I hadn't really worked with
before it felt a bit embarrassed said
okay let me try that again this is it
was just so weird
and then then it made total sense to me
that I was uh I had was pretty fragile
and so your voice reflects that got
better and I as I got stronger and kind
of reclaimed myself and everything came
clear to me my voice came back but I
think that's a little bit of a little
bit of Bonnie Raitt gravel but still
around I don't mind it because it feels
like it's experiences life experience
[Music]
the golden the country music sound you
know we've heard Madonna dude before I'm
dude we've heard Lady Gaga do it before
you concerned at all about people
comparing you to these artists doing the
same sort of thing no not at all as a
songwriter as a vocalist as a performer
there's you want to take inspiration
from everywhere it all moves and shape
shifts around so no I think I've just
I've enjoyed every second of it as they
probably did you know recently Shania
Twain got a little bit of fire for an
interview she gave where she said that
she would have supported Donald Trump or
would have voted for Donald Trump and
we're in an age where you have to be
careful about the things that you say
when you say an amendment and who you
say them a contradiction because at the
same time we're all we're all trying to
support freedom and I wasn't where of
that and who she's entitled to her
opinion yeah we would all should be do
you feel like you ever have to censor
yourself when you're giving in to here
or giving your opinion um I feel like in
general and not with you this is a
lovely chat sometimes doing press is
like it's like a chess game
and I'm not very good at cheating maybe
not so much now but I definitely
remember in the early days but you know
took a few hard knocks